domestically here or well
first i would say that um the
president's uh
set a clear objective from the beginning
which was to end the war
play any role we can ending the war and
bring it to a conclusion as quickly as
possible and at the beginning
that seemed highly unlikely given there
were thousands of rockets
falling on tel aviv and the israelis run
a war footing and preparing for
by many reports a ground invasion so i
would say what's important to look at
and reflect on here
is historic precedent and the fact that
the conflict in 2014
many more lives were lost also it went
on for 51
days so the president's view is that
and his view from the beginning was that
through disciplined intensive and
quite a disciplined intensive and quiet
campaign of diplomacy
and one where we would lead coordination
in the region we could bring an end to
the conflict more quickly than it was
intended to be
and it's also important to remember that
hamas is a terrorist organization
that uh israel of course continues to
have the right to defend itself
but what's most important from now uh
forward in his view
is uh to to contemplate where we go from
here
uh darlene and certainly he talked
yesterday about
replenishing support for the iron dome
and our view is that
saved hundreds of lives maybe more than
that given the effectiveness
also to support through the united
nations uh
continued additional assistance in
rebuilding gaza we've already of course
uh restarted our assistance that was
ended in 2018
through unrwa through the united states
but we'll work through the through the
u.n and we also will
remain engaged deeply uh with diplomatic
conversations with leaders in the region
so uh you know obviously anyone here
domestically will have to make
uh their own decisions but i would say
that um you know it's important to
convey what our intention was
what we feel that we feel this was
concluded
as a result of the president's
engagement
and um and frankly discipline from the
beginning
much faster than these conflicts have
been in the past
go ahead oh go ahead darling go ahead we
also heard this week a lot of
democrats shifting their tone on israel
so is is it time for the president or
the white house or the united states to
also
perhaps start thinking about shifting
the approach
shifting what are what's shifting in
what way
you had a lot of democrats who were
frustrated
that the president didn't call
for a ceasefire immediately that was one
thing that a lot of people were upset
about
so and and the sort of
i don't want to say knee-jerk but the
u.s position is that israel has a right
to defend itself
and there are a lot of democrats who i
think
from what we heard them say this week
they don't necessarily
buy into that and so the thinking is is
there
some shift in the approach to israel
darlene i think the reason i answered it
the way i did is because obviously we
all shared
an objective of bringing an end to the
conflict the president's view
and his strategic approach and that of
his team was that the best way to do
that
was not to call out our allies and
partners but was to remain
closely coordinated and to work in
lockstep
and at the right moment uh to convey it
was time to wind it down
and that's exactly what he did and now
the conflict is concluded
in 11 days and uh frankly he resisted
calls to take an alternative approach
that in his view would have had an
alternative outcome
uh so uh that's why i answered it the
way i did go ahead oh one
i have one question sure uh yesterday we
had a ceremony here the bill signing a
large group of lawmakers
came we had the medal of honor ceremony
yesterday we're back
the meeting with the kennedy center
honors that we were told president first
lady had
i've seen handshakes hugging kissing
yes is the white house open again can
you talk about some of the
considerations that went into
um these events over the past couple of
days and is this the norm the new norm
the new norm going forward i can confirm
we are a warm and fuzzy crew and we like
to hug around here
but we were waiting for that to be
allowed by cdc guidelines which we
certainly abide by
so we are as many organizations and
companies are working to implement
these guidelines here at the white house
and so what you've seen
over the last couple couple of days is
efforts to do
uh exactly that and that includes uh
welcoming back and having a full uh
briefing room very soon
uh it includes uh having more events
with more people
and certainly continuing to open the
white house up
the people's house up to the american
public
go ahead thanks back to israel for a
moment one of the other examples i think
that would fit into
darlene's question is this pressure from
lawmakers over the 735
million dollar pending sale of precision
guided missiles to israel
you know the president said yesterday
he's committed to replenishing the iron
dome
but is he also committed to making sure
that sale goes through
we have no plans to change our security
assistance
that we're providing to israel but i
will say that the president's view
is through is that we need to do we need
to move forward on a couple of fronts
certainly supporting the security of
israel is one of them
but another front is rebuilding playing
a constructive role in rebuilding gaza
providing assistance
and funding through the human efforts to
do exactly that ensuring that it is
not hamas but is the palestinian people
who benefit from that assistance and
doing that through the un
is in our view the best way to do that
it also includes uh continuing to have
engaged diplomacy with leaders in the
region uh continuing discussions with
officials across the middle east
egyptians israelis
palestinian leaders cutteries others
about how we move forward
from here on police reform
looks like this sort of soft memorial
day deadline
is going to slip without legislation
being passed
is the white house losing some
confidence in the bipartisan talks that
are going on capitol hill
and also how does president biden plan
to address that issue on tuesday when he
speaks about the anniversary of george
floyd's death
well i would say first that the
president used the occasion
of his joint address one of the highest
profile moments any president has
to speak about reiterate his view that
it police reform is long overdue
a george floyd justice and policing act
is exactly the right
uh forum and a bill that could help uh
get that done
rebuild trust in communities uh what
we've seen from the negotiators and
we've been in close touch with the
negotiators as well
is that they still feel there's progress
being made yes it's unlikely
as they've conveyed as well we're going
to meet the timeline that that the
president outlined in his speech
uh which he did because he felt it was
important to lift it up
to be bold and ambitious and how we're
talking about such an important piece of
legislation
but we have confidence in the
negotiators and we've seen them
convey publicly that they feel the vibes
are good and they're continuing to make
progress
go ahead nation is the president
confident that this ceasefire will hold
and
if so can you explain a bit why did he
receive any kinds of assurances
from prime minister netanyahu well we
have strong assurances
assurances sorry i don't know why that
was a hard word let me try again
we have strong assurances from the
relevant parties uh that they are
committed
to the ceasefire and obviously this is
something we will be watching
extremely closely in the coming days and
i think uh what's important to note is
in the final 24 hours leading up to the
ceasefire
obviously the president was deeply
engaged before that but he was very it
was especially deeply engaged in that
period of time
as were high-level senior officials here
and they were uh back and forth on the
phone between
many different parties the israelis the
egyptians who were in touch with hamas
and others
about the importance of not violating
even pre-violating the ceasefire and the
hours leading up to it as we see
uh did not happen so we will be in close
touch with all parties
we clearly will be watching it but we do
have assurances from the relevant
parties that they are committed
and yesterday before this was announced
he said you expected israel to start
winding down their operations
because they achieved significant
military objectives
so how much of the timing of this do you
think is because of the president's
diplomatic approach
and how much of this is simply because
the israelis have exhausted much of
their targets in gaza
well i think what's again important to
remember is to point back to how these
conflicts have worked in the past
and we have seen these conflicts last
for
weeks and weeks many many more lives
lost now we certainly know there were
lives lost
in this 11 day conflict everyone is a
tragedy
but certainly because of the president's
deep engagement
his long relationships the fact that he
set a clear objective from the beginning
that we were going to put out the noise
and focus on our strategy of deep
intensive
quiet diplomacy have conversations uh
not
call out our partners and allies and do
that to do it do our engagements through
uh through one-on-one conversations uh
we certainly think
uh that had an impact uh now of course
we also were watching closely uh where
and and we're in touch with them closely
about
uh about their uh military successes and
certainly that was
a part a factor but a part of the
discussion as well
and sort of a scheduling question here
there had been an expectation that there
was going to be a conversation of some
kind
today between republicans on the hill
some officials here at the white house
about the status of
infrastructure and republican counter
proposal is that meeting still happening
today
and can you give us kind of an update on
where things stand
uh and any movement that may or may not
be happening sure um it is happening it
may be ongoing as we speak
but it started shortly before uh one
o'clock over a video conference this
afternoon
uh our team including steve roshetti
louise atterl brian d
secretary raimondo and secretary buda
judge put forward a reasonable
counter offer that reduces the size of
the package from
2.25 trillion in additional investment
to 1.7
trillion and in our view this is the act
uh the art i should say of seeking
common ground
this proposal exhibits a willingness to
come down in size
giving on some areas uh that are
important to the president otherwise
they wouldn't have been in the proposal
while also staying firm in areas that
are most vital to rebuilding our
infrastructure and industries of the
future
making our workforce and our country
more competitive with china
we actually have every intention to
share the complete
totality of the counter proposal with
you all we'll just wait for the
meeting to conclude to do that until
then can you say any more about
what was taken out to lower that price
tag sure let me give you kind of some
top line details and then again what the
kind of proposal that we'll put out is
very detailed so you'll see all the
specifics for yourself
but again i noted the top line number
that was offered
uh it our proposal also involved
a shifting uh and shifting investments
in research and development supply
chains manufacturing
and small business out of the
negotiation into other efforts
such as the endless frontiers act and
the chips act which as you know there's
ongoing discussions in negotiations on a
bipartisan level
about those as well the president the
proposal also
agreed to reduce the funding request for
broadband to match the republican offer
and to reduce the proposed investment
in roads bridges and major projects to
come closer to the number
proposed by the senators this is all in
the spirit of finding
common ground now at the same time as i
alluded to
we also the counteroffer also reflects
our view that the republican offer
excludes entirely some proposals that
are key to our competitiveness uh key to
investments in clean energy and in
industries of the future and
rebuilding our workforce including
critical investments in our power sector
building and construction workforce
training veterans hospital construction
and the care economy so we push for
increased funding levels for critical
transportation infrastructure like rail
especially considering china's level of
investment in such projects
as well as the elimination of lead pipes
that poison drinking water and
resilience projects
as extreme weather events as we've seen
around the country continue to become
more common as a result of climate
change
and lastly any changes to how you would
like to pay for all of this
uh we also reiterated or the intention
is to reiterate um
uh the fact that the president is not
willing to raise taxes on americans
earning under four hundred thousand
dollars a year
through a gas tax or through user fees
he believes that the
extraordinarily wealthy uh that
companies uh that
many of whom have not paid taxes uh in
recent years
uh can afford a modest increase to pay
for middle-class jobs
uh look do you have another question
very good okay go ahead just heard you
describe the infrastructure negotiations
as the art of seeking common ground
at some point does that become the art
of the deal i don't know i think
you're the professional here peter
you're the tv star
you know what's the fox chiron gonna be
uh art of seeking common ground does
take a lot of characters
we'd be okay with that yeah with the art
of the deal i think that's a headline
well there you go an art of a different
kind of deal a deal for the working
people
got it okay go ahead so i'm glad we
could work that out thank you very much
uh
on israel how much credit does president
biden think he deserves
for the ceasefire that was negotiated by
the president
of egypt well first of all
the president uh focus was on one
objective which was bringing an end to
the conflict as quickly as possible
as you know and as as as our briefing
day in and day out was evidence of
there was criticism and as darlene's a
question was evidence of there was
criticism coming from
many sides we kept our head down focused
on our strategic objective
focused on intensive quiet diplomacy to
uh bring an end to the conflict as
quickly as possible uh
our engagements with the leaders of
egypt uh what were was it
the leader of egypt was a key part of
that discussion uh and a key part of
bringing an end to the conflict given
their important relationships with hamas
because we are just trying to understand
all these the dozens of calls and
who played what role the president
extended his sincere gratitude to
president al-sisi
and the other senior egyptian officials
who played a critical role in the
diplomacy so if their role was critical
how does white house describe president
biden's role well
again peter i think what i can do here
what what the president was conveying is
that this was an effort
much of it coordinated by the united
states much of which he was involved in
personally uh engagements on the phone
engagements with his team
uh a commitment and a driving desire to
keep the strategy aligned with what we
knew
uh would help uh bring an end to the
conflict as quickly as possible
he's also someone who wants to give
credit where credit is due and that
includes
the role the egyptians played and the
role many countries in the region played
in
uh in working to bring an end to the
conflict and then quickly
and also his team i mean he called out
secretary of state tony blinken he
called out
his national security adviser and also
our un ambassador
thomas greenfield who played an
important role here as well uh quickly
on immigration the governor of tennessee
says that he was asked and he declined a
biden administration request
to house unaccompanied minors and in
coming days or in recent days there have
been some reports that at least four
planes
filled with unaccompanied minders landed
in his state some in the middle of the
night
can you explain what's going on there
well as we have been very clear about
children our objective is to unite these
unaccompanied children
children under the age of 18 with
families with sponsor families so
children
traveling through we're traveling
through have been traveling through
tennessee
uh they're simply on their way to unite
with relatives and sponsors to meet
sponsors in the state or just traveling
through tennessee
until they reach another destination to
unite with family members or
legal sponsors as you know
geographically it's
right in a place where you know there's
a lot of states around it so
it's a place where some flights have
gone through as children are moving to
other destinations and since this was
something that the governor of the state
said he didn't want this is not
a case of federal officials trying to
sneak something past
the state level officials i think i'm
confirming here that
tennessee is a state that is right near
in the middle of the country and some
kids have to travel
through there to get through their
destination and we've been very clear
that our objective is to
treat these kids humanely get them to
safe homes especially
homes of loved ones and sponsored
families
go ahead uh the point of clarification
you mentioned uh detailed some of the
cuts
to the encounter proposal did i hear you
right
they're going to find a home in other
senate legislation that's carling
through now like the china bill so you
while they're coming out of your county
proposal they are going to find a phone
so
there are some components yeah where
there is um some overlap in the
frontiers bill and the chips bill
uh where there is opportunity to still
move forward on some of the president's
ideas
gotcha republican governors in some 22
states
have rolled back their expanded
unemployment benefits
what is the white house or the bond
administration doing to
to to preserve those benefits if
anything at the state level
well jared uh it is up to of course
these governors to make a decision about
what assistance they want to provide
to the people of their states our view
continues to be that
unemployment insurance of course at a
federal level which is something we
advocate for and would work to pass
through
congress or have work to pass through
congress is something that can help
people during a time where there are
still more than 8 million people out of
work
make ends meet and that there is not
overwhelming
data that suggests that uh it is a
driving factor in people not
uh re-entering the workforce especially
at a time where we're continuing to
recover from the pandemic but is
ultimately up to governors to make those
government can do just decisions be
clear we can continue to convey what we
see in the data
what we advocate for in terms of what we
think will help get people back on their
feet
and we used every opportunity to do that
the washington brochures reported
some details on the upcoming budget
specifically that the um
the the public option to create a
government-run health insurance program
and a pledge to cut
prescription drug costs we're not going
to be in that budget proposal anything
you comment on that well we'll be uh
announcing and rolling out the
president's
proposed budget uh a week from today
buckle up i know it's a big day for
reuters those days
um and i'm not going to get too far
ahead of that but what i will tell you
is that what it will outline
uh is how we're proposing
to pay for a range of the proposals the
president has put forward and
he's clearly talked about and remains
committed to his
campaign pledge of pushing for a public
option to
doing something to address the rising
cut cost of prescription drugs something
he talked about
in his joint session address but every
entity may not be reflected in this
budget
go ahead thanks jen back to the middle
east
prime minister netanyahu seemed to
ignore president
requests for a de-escalation of the
violence
over several days and then a truce was
struck
once egypt stepped in so i guess the
question is
why should people have confidence that
president biden will be able to work
with him for a de-escalation
should there be another player through
with prime minister netanyahu
i would just have to say kristin that i
don't think that's how any of the
parties involved
the prime minister uh the egyptian
president or this president would
characterize what happened over the last
11 days and obviously some of this is
going to remain
um continue to be remain behind the
behind the scenes through what what what
was quiet diplomacy over the course of
11 days
but uh there's no question that uh the
president's engagement
uh both with the israeli prime minister
both with uh the
with the president of egypt uh with
leaders in the region
uh our commitment to staying disciplined
and remaining focused on our overarching
objective of bringing an end to the
conflict as quickly as possible
um was uh contributed to uh to
the ceasefire we saw last night well i
guess what i'm asking about is based on
your
own readouts from the white house
president biden
pressed prime minister netanyahu to
de-escalate the violence
and then in later phone calls urged a
ceasefire
and that didn't happen and there was a
ceasefire last night and he urged for a
ceasefire about two days in advance of
that
and again i would say that the
president's objective from the beginning
was to have these conversations quietly
to work in close coordination
with the prime minister about how we
could bring an end to the conflict
recognizing fully that at the same time
there were thousands of rockets
coming into cities in israel from hamas
and uh that was something the prime
minister uh was going to work to defend
and the president said yesterday that he
told prime minister netanyahu he would
replenish the iron
system did he offer that as a promise in
order
to reach this ceasefire and were there
any concessions made
as a part of this deal first of all the
president did that because
uh conveyed that because he felt that
the effectiveness of the iron dome
helped save hundreds of lives
and it remains the president remains
steadfast of course in his support of
israel's right to defend itself
uh but also believes that um the
effectiveness of the iron dome is
something that we should continue to
support and will continue to support as
united states
any concessions made by the united
states by the
let me ask you domestically you just
said it's
unlikely they will reach a deal on the
george floyd policing act
by next tuesday well the negotiators
have conveyed that correct yes they've
conveyed that
what will the pressure point be if not
this one year anniversary how does
president biden make sure
this gets done and if you speak to civil
rights groups interest groups
they want it done this summer well first
of all
with the all of the negotiators are
continuing to press forward
on working to find common grand ground
to get this done
the president wants to sign it into law
and of course
the anniversary george floyd's death
something that impacted the president
personally and deeply as it impacted
millions of americans
was a moment to call for action to call
for forward movement
but the negotiators by all accounts are
continuing to make progress
they're continuing to have good
discussions and uh that is a positive
sign
so you know we are not going to slow our
slow our efforts to get this done but we
can also be transparent about the fact
that it's going to take a little bit
more time
that sometimes that happens and that's
okay by the summer does the president
want this done by the summer
the president wants to sign into law as
quickly as possible to follow up on
something that mary was asking me this
counter proposal yeah
can you tell us specifically about the
corporate tax rate
has there been any change to the
corporate tax rate has it come down to
25
something that democrats were asking for
well again our counter proposal was
primarily focused on the areas of
investment
as you'll see when we provide the
specific details and
what i reiterated to which is the
president's bottom line about not
raising taxes on people
making less than four hundred thousand
uh the uh republican uh ranking members
and leaders to
take a fresh look at uh the fact that
many corporations can afford to pay a
little bit more taxes and so can many on
the highest income
that was really what was in our kind of
proposal in terms of what was discussed
in the meeting i don't have a read out
of that
to the corporate tax rate that you're
aware of well i mean the proposal of the
corporate i'm not a mathematician
otherwise i wouldn't be here
but obviously we proposed a package that
was 500 billion dollars less expensive
so it needs less pay fors uh but what
that looks like
uh will have to be a part of the
negotiation um go ahead
uh thanks i'm hoping you can give us an
update on
um international inbound travel
wondering if the administration i wish i
could
well it's a very popular question well
i was going to ask if the administration
feels any urgency
ahead of the summer high season to make
any new policy moves well we certainly
understand the desire of
many europeans to come travel to the
united states
and vice versa and um and uh
people that's part of returning to
normal and part of
uh what will make people feel good about
the efforts to fight the pandemic but
we can't respond to public pressure or
even emotion
we have to rely on the health and
guidance the guidance of our health and
medical experts which is exactly what
we'll do
but in terms of that guidance at this
point that the cdc is saying for
vaccinated individuals they can
go in and outside uh large crowds
small crowds uh you know
they said that vaccinated individuals
can travel yeah internationally and
they're still required to wear masks and
airline travel is a little different and
again i'm not i'm not a doctor
but we rely on their advice and they
obviously are continuing to consider and
update
uh guidance as information becomes
available and in terms of um
possibly requiring uh you know proof of
vaccination for non-us citizens
is there any uh further consideration of
that
a vaccine passport i didn't use that sir
well you mean the same basic thing the
federal government requiring
vaccines
that is not in our intended plan on a
different topic
on um colonel uh yeah
why was maybe you could take us a little
bit into the decision
to have him be the first recipient of a
medal of honor for the president well
clearly he has an incredible personal
story and is part of
what the president feels is one of the
greatest generations uh
in history and uh he also has um
a great deal of support uh for the
sacrifices he made
and the incredible story we just heard
the president tell
at that event um you know it's and the
president i think felt it was important
to
honor him recognize him um you know
uh as one of the first people um
given the service that he paid to the
country and
uh you know the fact that he is still a
young man
but uh someone we want to recognize
while his family can celebrate with him
go ahead ann let me try a different
version of kristen's question okay
so on wednesday the readout of the
president's call
with the prime minister was pretty blunt
in saying that the president had told
the prime minister he expected to see
a significant de-escalation that day
wednesday
the cease-fire didn't come until more
well more than 24 hours later well
36 hours later 2 a.m friday local time
uh was the president concerned and was
there
was there any consternation around here
as the day wore
on on wednesday and moved into thursday
uh that the prime minister
was blowing him off uh not listening to
him
not doing what the president had asked
him to do
no and that is not a reflection of what
happened behind the scenes either
clearly the president felt it was
important to convey
uh even in a public readout that uh his
view and the view of the united states
was it was time to move toward a
ceasefire
and just over 24 hours later there was
an agreed ceasefire
and that required additional
conversations behind the scenes many of
which the president was involved in
himself as you well know
because we did readouts of them it
required also an agreement as you know
and from
the other side and required an agreement
from hamas
that they also would engage in the
ceasefire hence the conversation the
president had
with president el-sisi uh on thursday
just yesterday morning
that was uh an a factor that led to
that agreement on that side so uh it was
the moment
in the discussions and negotiations
where the president felt it was
important to convey that publicly
obviously he uh was careful about what
he
uh conveyed publicly what he said
publicly what we said in readouts
publicly but
it was a reflection of that but over the
last 24 to 36 hours were clearly pivotal
in
bringing an end to the conflict but it's
unusual for a president to throw a flag
like that
and to say to a foreign leader that
effectively
the u.s president is setting a deadline
for specific
action if that specific action isn't met
in the deadline of the president's sets
even though i completely take your point
that there was a ton of other stuff
happening
and it wasn't a terribly long much
longer time period
than the one the president has set is
there a risk
that the president looks uh in any way
uh weak or ineffective in having set the
deadline to begin
well first of all there was a ceasefire
in 11 days
that was uh one-fifth of the length of
time of the 2014 conflict with far fewer
lives lost
this was accomplished in part because of
intensive quiet diplomacy
where we did not make him or leaders in
the united states the center pieces of
this effort
because we felt that was not uh that
that the most important thing we could
do was play a role behind the scenes
that's exactly what we did uh the
conflict has now ended
there is a ceasefire just over 24 hours
after that call was made
and that was an important point to
convey publicly
but no that is not our view from here
on one other topic this month the
justice department has
informed washington post reporters yeah
and then this week
cnn reporter that the previous
administration
had obtained their phone records as part
of
investigations into presumed leaks that
led to news stories
what is this administration's view of
the appropriateness of these
seeking reporters phone records and do
you plan to continue those
investigations
well first i will say that i learned
this issue for the first time after
cnn's report yesterday
and i know similar sentiments have been
expressed from
many parts of this government as i
understand that the record sought and
the legal process to obtain them began
as you noted during the prior
administration uh we of course this
president is committed
strongly to the rights of the freedom of
press as you have seen for decades and
standing up for the rights of
journalists and the justice department
conveyed yesterday that they intend to
meet with reporters to hear their
concerns about
recent notices and they certainly intend
to use
the holder model as their model not the
model of the last
several years but really these decisions
would be up to the justice department
well the holder
model included pretty significantly
aggressive leak investigations the
specific question though is the
appropriateness of seizing
seeking and seizing personal phone
records from journalists do you does
this administration believe that's an
appropriate tactic
well again uh it was done by the prior
department of justice
i would send you to the department of
justice for any comment and what their
intentions are moving forward
go ahead there was a marissa came out
earlier weighing
um race relations in the u.s with 17 of
people saying that they did not believe
um that things had uh well i'm sorry 17
believing
only 70 things had changed earlier you
talked about police reform and what the
administration is doing you mentioned
building trust in communities but what
does that actually mean
well i think the reason i reference that
is because
obviously passing or our view i should
say is passing the george floyd justice
and policing act
uh into law ensuring that there is more
accountability
uh more requirements and restrictions in
place
for departments across the country and
also would be
a a contribution to rebuilding trust in
communities obviously there's more that
needs to be done
beyond that that's not the only step far
from it but
i think our view and the president's
view is that signing this bill into law
would make a contribution also what
concerns
with concerns among parents about
potential long-term effects on
children associated that have gotten the
vaccine
what type of any type of surveillance
outside the two-year plan that's been
described by pfizer
has the administration considered um to
help kind of quell the concerns of
parents
um just to understand your question you
mean surveillance of the impacts on kids
well first i would say that the most
important um thing we can
say a message we can convey from this
administration is
it's okay to have questions and concerns
and your primary care physicians and
doctors
are the absolutely the right people to
answer these questions
now and a year from now and three years
from now and certainly there has been
a great deal the the the the process of
approving vaccines
in the united states is the gold
standard we have the highest standards
in the world
and uh our health and medical experts
are confident in that
but we also know i'm a parent many of us
are parents
parents have questions about what this
means for their kids and that's okay
that's valid that's one of the reasons
why we are trying to fund and empower
local leaders civic leaders medical
experts
partnering with primary care physicians
so that parents feel like they can ask
these questions
to people they trust right who they've
been taking their kids to for years
lastly the department of agriculture
today published the first notices of the
funding available
um and so for black bombers who've been
talking about they have felt like
there's a lot of racism within that
system
we know that the banks had sent a letter
to secretary vilsack earlier
pushing back on those funds being
available
and many farmers took it as a threat
what is the administration prepared to
do
if we start to see that then banks don't
um offer any loans to black farmers
because of that decision
well i know this is uh very much on the
mind of secretary vilsack in terms of
ensuring equity
and how these funds are being
distributed and delivered around the
country
i probably have to check with the
department of agriculture and kind of
the status of this letter i haven't been
following this as closely
go ahead in the back um on
infrastructure you mentioned uh
some of the items removed in this yeah
this counter offer kind of migrating to
other
proposals other depending on solution
could some of those then be included in
the family's plan
well look i think the reason i reference
the um
the chips uh proposal and of course the
frontiers proposals because as you know
those are negotiating and working their
way through in a bipartisan fashion
at this point in time but as i've also
said from here but i'll restate
uh what the president's put forward is a
is a bunch of large bold ideas
right the mechanisms and the mechanics
of how they move forward we're very open
to working with congress on what that
looks like so
there is some overlap in some of the
pieces proposed in the jobs plan with
some of the components in the chips plan
and the frontiers plan
hence there's an opportunity to move
those ideas forward uh
but beyond that uh you know obviously
he'll continue to press for these
in the months ahead and the um original
proposal had pretty ambitious plans for
electric vehicles yeah he references a
little bit before but
a lot of gop skepticism about some of
those plans so in the counter proposal
are you guys ratcheting back on those at
all
yes absolutely and again you'll see the
specifics when we put out
the um our entire counter proposal but
certainly
investments in the electric vehicle
industry charging stations
uh industries of the future which in our
view are going to be the backbone of
communities around the country including
communities like dearborn where the
president was earlier this week
are areas where we feel we need to
continue to invest to be competitive
with china and
boost our workforce uh go ahead in the
back
the administration has said that it
wants to work with japan and south korea
to stand up to china's aggression
but as you know south korea and china
they're heavily
dependent on south korea and japan's
economies are heavily dependent on china
and there's also been some reports about
the south korean side being reluctant to
add any language that might
upset the chinese in today's joint
statement so how is the administration
going to work with south korea and japan
to when it comes to standing up to
beijing when their economies
are so closely tied to china
well first let me say that it is should
send a clear message about the
importance of these partnerships and
alliances that
the first two bilateral meetings the
president had has had
after today are with japan and south
korea and obviously there are a range of
means we can
me coordinate and communicate uh with
both of those countries
um including through our trilateral um
discussions that we've already
participated in a very high level from
the federal government with our national
security advisor and our secretary
of state we certainly recognize that
fundamentally our two countries
the united states and south korea may
look at uh
aspects of our relationship with china
similarly in some aspects
differently and that will be a part of
our discussion and a part of what we
understand
going into these uh discussions that are
ongoing
now uh but uh you know at the end of the
day we feel there's areas of cooperation
and partnership with south korea as you
know there was a
big announcement that was made today
which we welcomed which is significant
investments
in the united states by south korean
companies totaling more than 25 billion
dollars
which that reflects the long-standing
close economic ties between the united
states and south korea
and we expect there to be continued
opportunities for those type of economic
uh
engagements and cooperation just one
more there's as you know there's ongoing
tension between south korea and japan
will the president we urge president
today
to improve its relationship with japan
well first we continue to promote
expanded trilateral
u.s south korea japan cooperation
again you've seen that through the
trilateral meetings that we've had at a
very high level
we not only want to strengthen america's
relationship with our allies but also
between our allies and nowhere is that
more important than between south korea
and japan
uh so certainly uh there's a range of
topics they'll discuss and they'll have
a press conference to talk about all of
it
go ahead thank you oh i'm sorry go right
to you next i'll go
i will not forget you sorry i was
jumping around go ahead thanks jen
i wanted to ask about president biden's
conversation with
rasheed of talib on the tarmac in
michigan what was his reaction to what
she
said which was reported to be that
she told him the u.s can't continue to
give the right-wing net yahoo government
billions of dollars
to commit crimes against the
palestinians well the president uh
spoke about how impressed he was by
congresswoman talib
at the event he had after he had the
conversation with her so i think he
spoke to
uh that already and certainly he
understands that there are a range of
viewpoints
uh as it relates to uh the conflict in
the middle east which we were in the
heat of over the last
several days and he felt it was
important to have a discussion with her
on the tarmac so he could convey his
point of view
certainly hear hers and uh you know
he'll look forward to
continuing to engage moving forward go
ahead
thanks jen i'm following up on darlene's
question about the white house being
open of course now we're all masked off
at least for the press
yeah um i can i can only speak to our
experience here it seems to be
on the honor system if we're vaccinated
or not so now the white house is having
these events
mass was hugging today and yesterday and
i assumed you know kind of fourth right
from here
how is the white house tracking
vaccinations beyond the folks who got
back to the god bless you on tv like
pelosi at all for the folks who we
haven't seen vaccine on tv
how is the white house tracking those
effects
well again what the guidance provided
was um
information so people could take steps
to protect themselves
either to get vaccinated which every
american is eligible who's over the age
of 12 at this point in time
or to mask up if they're not yet
vaccinated
so the steps we're taking here so that
means every individual
in the white house members of the press
corps can do exactly that
either get vaccinated or wear a mask
so the honor system is really about i
don't actually even like that term
because i think it's confusing i'm not
saying you're intending to do that
but the real question is how will people
who are not yet vaccinated protect
themselves
right because people who are vaccinated
what the cdc guidance is saying is that
you're protected so people who are not
vaccinated the guidance is you should
wear a mask
okay the white house is not going to go
on his way to necessarily verify
this individual or like i have been
vaccinated or not so she's cleared to
wear a mask that's not the but that's
not the role we're going to play
awesome just want to certify and then uh
a quick follow-up on the
budget proposal coming out next week a
couple of things that were not
included were very progressive ideas
like drug reform a certain debt relief
and you touch on this a little bit
earlier if you just want to get
a clarification a message to
progressives who might feel a little bit
chipped or let down that you know they
voted providing to get these specific
things through in the first 100 days of
the first year and they feel like well
maybe that's not going to be
accomplished for them
so any message directed to those well
first i would say again we'll roll out
the totality of the budget you'll have
more paper and fact sheets than you know
what to do with um a week from today and
so i don't want to get too far ahead of
that
but what is important for people to
remember is that the president talked
about his commitment to the lowering the
cost of prescription drugs
in his joint session address he remains
committed to
uh continuing to make uh health care
more affordable and more accessible for
americans is the totality of everything
he wants to accomplish in his presidency
done in the first hundred days clearly
not because we've passed that period of
time
and will every single thing he wants to
get done in his presidency
be reflected in the budget it won't but
that doesn't mean he's not committed to
it and it doesn't mean that he's
doesn't have a desire to move all of
these agenda items forward that he
talked about in his joint session
address
and that he talked about when he was
running for president go ahead in the
back
house speaker nancy pelosi's call for a
diplomatic
boycott of the 2022 beijing olympics
does president biden agree with that
urging
our position hasn't changed at all
human rights and all and as much as this
administration
forcefully defends human rights we are
quite outspoken
on human rights the values of the united
states uh in
our conversations with the chinese
government and leaders
and any country where we have concerns
as was clear in the readout uh that
from the president's call with president
xi and as has been clear and every
engagement we've had
with the chinese leaders uh but our
position on the beijing olympics has not
changed
the uh in light of the israeli
palestinian fighting uh genocide against
the uyghurs the player of their wing uh
persecution of christians across the
globe this is the big question here
going forward how is that administration
going to
foster international religious freedom
there was a lot wrapped up in there what
i will tell you is that broadly speaking
the president
and the administration the secretary of
state will continue to advocate for
freedom of religion freedom of
expression
freedom of media around the world uh
when they have engagements
diplomatically when we have bilateral
meetings
through public and private uh
conversations closer to home
finally uh we've seen gas prices rising
much different topic here gas prices
rising significantly and we all know
that they
hurt poor people they hit them the
hearts right every
every dollar that comes why it's so
perplexing that some are proposing user
fees
but it's another topic well you want to
continue on your
go ahead i don't know you had a question
my question is is
if the abiding administration considered
does it have any
plan or any sort of action it can take
to try to bring down prices or at least
somehow
make the cost less whether it's a tax or
something to help impoverished people
otherwise the money that's going to in
the form of the rescue plan the other
money
is really money going back out the door
to pay for higher gas isn't it
well first i would say that uh the
president's plans his proposals whether
it was the american rescue plan his
american jobs plan his american family's
plan
have all been proposed through the prism
of what he can do to help working people
help people trying to make ends meet
help people trying to put food on the
table
his proposals have helped cut childhood
poverty in half by this this year
it's helped bring uh put 1.5 million
people back to work
uh has helped ensure that families and
parents
have a little bit of extra assistance so
they can cover the cost of child care
so that has been the prism through which
he's made all of his proposals i have to
wrap this up in a minute here
what did you mean when you said that
when it comes to spying on journalists
this doj is going to follow the holder
model because
eric holder was the attorney general
when the doj
was spying on the associated press and
was obtaining home records for
heroes and individual journalists well
the question that was asked which was a
good question was about the
uh the records that were uh taken or
seized or whatever however you want to
characterize it um
during the last administration and we're
not going to follow the bar model
uh and uh i would say i would point you
to our department of justice to how they
will approach that issue
you said the holder model and eric
holder did
monitor the phone records of journalists
i think i would point to the department
of justice here this all these decisions
would be made by our attorney general in
the department of justice
and again they are going to be meeting
with journalists to hear their concerns
uh and certainly we will continue to
advocate for freedom of press freedom of
expression
uh in the united states of course but
also around the world thank you everyone
oh i'm sorry i always i don't
unintentionally forget
um it's my favorite part of the week go
ahead hello how are you
i'm good thank you jen for the
opportunity my name is andrew peng i'm
with the yappy a publication
dedicated to tracking asian american
pacific islander activism
i have two questions uh the first one's
on anti-asian hate
uh in addition to the kobe 19 hate
crimes act that the president signed
yesterday the administration
also announced plans back in march to
re-establish the white house initiative
on asian-american-pacific islanders
the white house also said that the
president would appoint a permanent
director to leave that initiative
um do we have any announcements or can
we expect an update on an executive
order
reauthorizing initiative sure well thank
you it's very nice to meet you thanks
for all the reporting you do
uh i will first say that um reinstating
and expanding the white house initiative
on asian american and pacific islanders
and ensuring that it
is successful is a top priority for the
president he's committed to
re-establishing the initiative as he
talked about
early on in his presidency uh we hope to
have more on that
soon um so soon coming weeks on more
specifics and an update
as you noted he signed into law a
bipartisan bill
the covet hate crimes bill legislation
yesterday first big event here at the
white house with bipartisan support
welcome people to the white house that
just conveys how important that
legislation was to him
and he also committed to appointing a
senior member of his white house team
which he has done who has a seat at the
table both on
policy and personnel uh to speak to the
uh the initiatives that are important to
the aapi
community but hopefully we'll have more
soon maybe if we're having this
conversation next week i'd have more of
an update but
it could be that soon but it's very nice
to meet you thanks for joining us in the
briefing room
thanks for everyone so much and have a
wonderful weekend
you